Ils sont 150 000.
Et ils ne sont là que par la
volonté d'un seul homme.
Ensemble sous la même bannière.
Unis dans un même geste.
Prêts à le suivre jusque dans la guerre.
Jusque dans la folie.
Lui, leur guide, leur führer.
Peu de noms,
Résonnent avec autant de force
dans l'histoire contemporaine,
Comme celui d'Adolf Hitler.
Peu d'hommes restent associés,
Dans la mémoire collective
à pareil sentiment d'horreur et de haine.
Par ses discours nationalistes et fanatiques,
Il a galvanisé tout un peuple.
Et la précipiter dans le conflit
le plus meurtrier du XXᵉ siècle,
La Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Cinq ans de guerre.
Plus de 60 millions de ****.
La face du monde,
En a été changée.
Et le traumatisme a marqué des générations.
70 ans après sa mort,
L'histoire du leader nazi conserve
encore ses zones d'ombre.
Comment un homme venu de nulle-part
s'est il hissé au sommet,
Pour commettre les pires crimes de guerre,
Et le pire crime jamais commis contre l'humanité ?
C'est cette histoire que nous allons vous raconter.
Comment imaginer que ce petit garçon
au visage poupon,
Sera un jour le responsable
de l'horreur absolue.
Car au départ,
Il était destiné à une vie sans relief,
Une vie dans l'anonymat le plus total.
Celui que l'on appellera plus tard le Führer,
Est né en Autriche,
Dans la province rurale de Linz,
Un jour d'avril 1889.
Il mène une adolescence sans histoire.
C'est un jeune garçon que rien
ne distingue de ses camarades,
Ni un premier de la classe,
Ni un cancre à proprement parler.
Ses maîtres savent qu'il est intelligent,
Et qu'il est aussi très paresseux,
Et qu'il est surtout extrêmement indiscipliné.
Si le jeune, Adolf Hitler,
Montre bien peu d'intérêt pour l'école.
Il a en revanche une passion.
Son temps libre,
Il le passe enfermé dans sa chambre à dessiner.
C'est son seul loisir.
Le dessin devient d'ailleurs très vite,
Bien plus qu'une simple lubie de gamin.
Il avait un beau coup de crayon,
Toute sa famille,
Dont personne n'avait de culture
en matière picturale,
S'extasiait devant ces dessins ou ces aquarelles.
Et à ce moment là,
Il le conçoit très jeune,
Vers 11, 12 ans.
Une vocation d'artiste peintre.
Une vocation d'artiste, donc,
Qui ne fait pas l'unanimité dans la famille.
Car son père, Alois,
A déjà une carrière toute tracée pour son fils,
Il sera fonctionnaire comme lui.
Son père rêve d'en faire un fonctionnaire
de la monarchie austro hongroise,
Et donc qu'il lui dit qu'il n'en est pas question.
Donc il y a effectivement des cris, des pleurs,
Peut être éventuellement des taloches.
Son père était un caractère violent,
Porté sur l'alcool,
Et qu'il y avait donc des crises de colère.
Mais alors qu'il a 13 ans,
Son père meurt subitement d'une crise cardiaque.
Alors Adolf Hitler sait que rien ne s'opposera plus,
À la voie qu'il a choisie.
Plus tard,
Il sera artiste.
Nous sommes en 1907.
Hitler a tout juste 18 ans.
Il quitte le foyer familial et sa province de Linz,
Au nord de l'Autriche.
Son objectif,
La capitale, à 200 km de là,
Vienne.
La ville est à l'époque un centre culturel majeur en Europe,
La grande rivale de Paris.
Un rendez vous incontournable pour les artistes,
Et les intellectuels du début du siècle.
Persuadé de son talent,
Adolf Hitler pense qu'ici,
Il pourra enfin percer en tant qu'artiste.
Et la voie royale.
Eh bien, c'est celle de l'Académie des Beaux-Arts.
Pour franchir les portes de cette institution,
Il faut passer un concours ultra sélectif.
Mais cela n'effraie pas Adolf Hitler.
Pour lui, ça ne fait pas l'ombre d'un doute.
L'examen d'entrée ne sera qu'une formalité.
C'est quelqu'un qui croit à la distinction naturelle,
Au génie,
À l'exceptionnalité.
On constate tout au long de la vie d'Hitler,
Et ça vaut pour le concours des Beaux-Arts,
Au premier chef,
Une confiance en soi réelle et très forte.
Il est persuadé qu'il va réussir quand il arrive,
Et il est persuadé qu'il sera pris
à l'Académie des Beaux-Arts.
Signé Adolf Hitler,
Voici les toiles qu'il peint à l'époque.
Si elle atteste d'un certain coup de crayon,
D'un travail soigné,
Elles ne font pas preuve d'une grande originalité.
C'est en tout cas l'avis de l'Académie des Beaux-Arts.
Son travail est jugé insuffisant par les professeurs.
Il est recalé.
Quand le verdict du jury tombe,
C'est un coup de poignard pour Hitler.
On peut dire, sans crainte de se tromper,
Qu'Adolf Hitler n'avait pas assez travaillé.
Qu'il y est allé, les mains dans les poches.
Parce qu'il était normalement doué en dessin.
Sans plus.
Dans son livre Mein Kampf des années plus tard,
Il décrira ce jour comme l'un des pires moments de sa vie.
"J'étais si persuadé du succès que l'annonce de mon échec,
Me frappa comme un coup de foudre dans un ciel clair."
Il ne s'y attendait absolument pas et il est anéanti.
Adolf Hitler n'accepte pas son échec,
D'autant qu'il en est persuadé,
S'il a échoué, ce n'est pas par manque de talent,
C'est le jury qui se trompe.
C'est un effet de frustration et de colère,
Vis à vis d'une institution.
Cet échec marque le début des années les plus noires,
De la vie de Hitler.
Une dégringolade sociale,
Une sorte de descente aux enfers.
Un épisode peu connu de son histoire.
Et pourtant,
C'est à cette époque que va grandir en lui une profonde,
Une viscérale haine des autres.
Bien que recalé par l'Académie des Beaux-Arts,
Adolf Hitler fait le choix de rester à Vienne.
Il passe ses journées retranché dans sa petite chambre de bonne,
De cet immeuble du centre ville.
Son échec, il n'en parle à personne,
Même pas à ses proches.
C'est une honte absolue.
Donc toute sa famille qui est à Linz,
Et ne sait pas qu'il a échoué aux Beaux-Arts,
Et croie qu'il est à Vienne,
En train de suivre les cours de cette école.
Le jeune Hitler vit sur le petit héritage laissé par sa mère,
Décédée 2 ans plus tôt.
Sans projets, sans perspectives,
Il s'enfonce dans l'amertume.
Et les jours passent,
Puis les semaines,
Puis les mois.
Il ne faisait rien de spécial,
Il se levait tard,
Il s'asseyait dans les cafés,
Il lisait beaucoup les journaux.
Il n'a aucune envie de travailler,
Ni comme fonctionnaire,
Ni comme employé quelque part.
Tout ça lui paraît en dessous de ce qu'il mérite,
Puisqu'il se voit comme comme un grand artiste.
Petit à petit,
Le jeune homme grignote toutes ses économies.
Bientôt, il n'a plus un sou en poche,
Même plus de quoi payer son loyer.
Il va devoir chercher refuge dans des foyers,
Et parfois se retrouver à la rue.
Certaines nuits, il dort sur les bancs publics.
Adolf Hitler a 20 ans et il est SDF.
Pour gagner quelques pièces,
Il peint des paysages,
Qu'il revend aux touristes.
Il vendait ses petites cartes, ses petits tableaux,
Quand il pouvait.
Il ne mangeait pas beaucoup,
Parce que ça ne rapportait pas grand chose.
Mais il était totalement marginal.
Cette vie d'errance va durer plusieurs années,
Des années durant lesquelles,
Adolf Hitler s'enfonce dans la rancœur.
Car il en est convaincu.
S'il en est arrivé là,
Ça ne peut pas être de sa faute.
D'autres que lui sont forcément responsables.
Les échecs sont toujours dus à des facteurs extérieurs ou à des personnes.
Donc il ne se remet pas en cause,
Et il considère qu'il est incompris.
C'est lié, évidemment.
Je pense à cette représentation de soi qu'il a,
Qu'il cultive de lui même,
Qui est son exceptionnalité et son génie.
Donc tout ce qui vient le contrarier,
Tout ce qui vient le démentir,
Ne peut être dû qu'à l'hostilité féroce,
Essentielle,
Mauvaise et quasi démoniaque d'ennemis qui lui veulent du mal.
Et ses ennemis qui lui veulent du mal,
Ceux sur qui il va rejeter la faute de ses échecs,
Adolf Hitler les a identifiés.
Ce sont des boucs émissaires tout trouvés à l'époque.
En Autriche dans les années 20,
Une partie de la presse fait porter la responsabilité,
De tous les problèmes de la société sur une catégorie de la population,
En particulier,
Les Juifs.
Cet antisémitisme,
Qui s'exprime ouvertement et sans ambiguïté,
Comme en témoigne ce journal, le Deutsches Volksblatt,
Le Journal du peuple allemand.
L'un des plus gros tirages à Vienne.
Dans cet article,
Le quotidien évoque,
Les dégradations économiques,
Dont les juifs sont responsables.
On les compare à une maladie qui gangrènerait la société autrichienne.
"L'élément juif est un corps étranger néfaste qui doit être évacué,
Afin que l'État et le peuple restent en bonne santé."
Dans cet autre article,
Un appel est lancé aux électeurs antisémites allemands,
En pleine élection à Vienne.
Les juifs sont montrés comme l'adversaire à abattre.
"L'électorat allemand ne doit pas suivre la devise électorale de la juiverie."
Les Juifs sont condamnés,
Répudiés,
Comme étant les anti nationaux par excellence.
C'est à dire des gens qui n'ont pas de feux ni de lieu,
N'ont pas de foi ni de lois et qui donc constituent une menace.
Hitler lit régulièrement cette presse antisémite,
Il se tourne même vers des lectures encore plus radicales.
L'une de ses favorites,
C'est une petite publication d'extrême droite,
Ostara.
Très explicite quant à sa haine des juifs,
Ici grossièrement caricaturé et menacé par un chevalier germanique.
Des idées qui font écho chez le jeune Adolf Hitler.
Il trouve dans cette presse les raisons de sa déchéance.
À cette époque,
Hitler se conçoit comme un exclu social.
Et lire toute cette littérature là,
Lire toute cette presse là,
Voir que les places sont prises,
Par des gens qui ne devraient pas y avoir accès,
Par des juifs.
Eh bien, cela, effectivement,
Nourrit son ressentiment social.
A cette époque, Hitler a 24 ans.
Il est en passe de rater sa vie.
Mais un événement extérieur va tout changer.
Un événement qui va faire basculer le cours de son destin.
À l'été 1914,
La Première Guerre mondiale éclate.
L'empire austro hongrois et l'Allemagne,
Entrent en guerre contre la France,
L'Angleterre et la Russie.
Hitler est autrichien,
Mais il s'engage aux côtés de l'armée allemande.
Car c'est le peuple allemand qu'il veut défendre.
Et dans ce conflit d'une violence inouïe,
Il va trouver un nouveau sens à sa vie.
Sur cette photo, le visage amaigri,
Barré d'une longue moustache où on le reconnaît à peine,
Il pose aux côtés de ses camarades de chambrée.
Et au sein de l'armée,
Le jeune homme va découvrir un cadre rassurant.
Et pour lui, c'est presque une révélation.
Au début de la Première Guerre mondiale,
Il est un homme sans famille.
En quelques semaines,
Il trouve un lieu ou il se sent bien.
Pour la première fois depuis le décès de sa mère.
Le jeune Adolf Hitler retrouve enfin un foyer.
Le soldat Hitler est nommé Estafette,
Une sorte d'agent de liaison chargé de délivrer les messages,
Entre les postes de commandement à l'arrière du front.
Et lui qui n'a toujours été qu'un élève médiocre,
Un peintre raté,
Devient un soldat modèle, dévoué et obéissant.
Pour la première fois de sa vie,
Adolf Hitler obtient même une reconnaissance.
L'armée le décor de la Croix de fer,
Une haute récompense militaire.
Ce sera l'une des plus grandes fiertés de sa vie.
Devenu führer des années plus tard,
Il ne s'en séparera jamais.
C'est quelque chose d'important sur le plan personnel.
C'est son premier diplôme,
C'est sa première distinction.
Dans l'armée, le jeune homme a enfin trouvé sa place.
Seulement voilà,
Le 11 novembre 1918,
L'Allemagne signe l'armistice.
La guerre est terminée.
Pour Adolf Hitler, c'est une tragédie.
Car cela signifie pour lui un retour à la case départ,
Un retour à sa vie d'avant,
Sans un sou,
Sans famille et sans repères.
Il n'a aucune envie de quitter l'armée,
C'est le seul milieu,
Où il a pu vivre à peu près correctement depuis son enfance.
Depuis qu'il a quitté le domicile familial.
S'il est démobilisé,
Il va se retrouver famélique,
À peindre des cartes postales et à essayer de les vendre.
Bon, et donc il va tout faire pour rester dans l'armée.
Et le jeune homme va justement bénéficier d'une aide précieuse,
Celle d'un homme qui va le prendre sous son aile.
Cet homme,
C'est Karl Mayr.
Son nom et son visage ne vous disent certainement rien,
Mais il va jouer un rôle décisif dans le parcours d'Adolf Hitler.
C'est lui qui va permettre au jeune homme de forger les racines,
De ce que sera bientôt l'idéologie nazie.
S'il y a une personne qui a fait Hitler,
C'est Karl Mayr qui va être,
Cet élément de passerelle d'Hitler.
Ce pied d'estale qui va lui permettre de rencontrer,
La capacité qui fera de lui le Führer,
Qui fera de lui le guide.
Karl Mayr est un homme important au sein de l'armée.
Il est le chef des services de renseignement.
Et au sortir de la guerre,
Il doit faire face à une menace au sein des troupes.
Des agitateurs d'extrême gauche,
Se trouvent parmi les soldats revenus du front.
Et Mayr craint que leurs idées ne se propagent.
Les dirigeants de l'armée étaient préoccupés,
Par le fait que ces soldats démobilisés,
Revenaient à la vie civile avec des idées de gauche,
Avec une mentalité de gauche.
Ils ont vu comment les bolcheviks ont réussi à prendre l'armée,
Le contrôle de l'armée en Russie.
Et ils se disent que ça pourrait très bien arriver chez eux.
Mayr,
Veut impérativement empêcher que ces mouvements extrémistes,
Ne contaminent toute l'armée.
Et pour cela, il a besoin d'hommes fiables,
Dévoués,
Qui surveilleront les brebis galeuses.
Alors il va recruter Adolf Hitler,
Qui lui,
Est prêt à tout pour rester dans l'armée.
Il commence comme un vulgaire petit indic,
Qui dit au commandement quels sont les soldats fiables,
Et quels sont les soldats qui ne le sont pas.
Il va dénoncer les copains.
En même temps, lui même,
Sans doute,
Là se trouve très patriote.
Il va aider à séparer l'armée des mauvais éléments.
Le jeune soldat a aussi d'autres qualités,
Que Mayr voit d'un très bon œil.
C'est un patriote virulent.
Et il possède un bagout hors pair.
C'est quelqu'un qui est atteint de logorrhée,
D'incontinence verbale quasi permanente.
Dès qu'il a l'occasion, il harangue les individus,
Il fait des discours.
Là effectivement meilleurs et les autres,
Vont se rendre compte qu'il a,
Une capacité très différente des autres à prendre la parole en public,
Et à parler notamment au peuple.
Hitler a tout pour devenir un bon propagandiste,
Mais il manque d'éducation et de culture.
Alors Mayr va l'envoyer à l'université de Munich prendre quelques cours.
Et c'est ici qu'Adolf Hitler va structurer sa pensée.
Il suit notamment des cours d'histoire et de politique.
Certains de ses enseignements vont l'intéresser tout particulièrement.
Car dans ces amphithéâtres, à l'époque,
Certains cours d'économie, par exemple,
Sont basés sur un antisémitisme radical.
Le capitalisme financier serait l'œuvre des Juifs,
Et viserait, en fait,
A dépecé les forces productives des différents pays.
Pour Hitler, c'est la révélation.
Il en fait sa pensée tout en le tirant vers son antisémitisme à lui,
Qui est un antisémitisme complètement fou,
Complètement obsessionnel,
Complètement radical,
Et complètement nouveau.
La haine des Juifs,
Devient le pivot de toute la pensée d'Hitler.
Et il va l'exprimer par écrit,
Avec des mots violents et crus,
Dans une lettre de 1919.
Cette lettre, la voici,
4 pages dactylographiées par Hitler lui même.
Elle est adressée à un soldat, Adolf Gemlich,
Qui l'interrogeait sur la question juive.
Et voici ce qu'Hitler répond.
Il affirme que les Juifs sont une race étrangère,
Qu'il compare à une tuberculose raciale des peuples.
Plus loin,
Il dit être en faveur d'un antisémitisme raisonné,
Qui doit conduire à une lutte méthodique sur le plan légal,
Et à l'élimination des privilèges du Juif.
La lettre se conclut par une menace à peine voilée.
L'objectif final doit être l'éloignement définitif du Juif.
Il y a le début d'une théorie politique antisémite,
Qui déjà,
Dit clairement que le but sera la entfernung,
C'est à dire l'expulsion violente des juifs de la société allemande.
Cela veut dire séparer,
Séparer le bon grain allemand,
Du mauvais grain juif.
Et donc dissocier ces 2 éléments.
Et puis éloigner.
Il y a aussi l'idée d'exiler, de les mettre dehors.
Hitler a tout juste 30 ans.
C'est son premier acte politique.
Un texte qui pose les bases de son antisémitisme absolu.
Et s'il n'est encore qu'un petit sous officier,
Qui partage ses idées dans les cercles militaires,
Hitler ne va pas tarder à propager,
Son idéologie bien au delà des frontières de l'armée.
C'est lors d'une mission secrète que tout va se jouer.
Nous sommes le 12 septembre 1919 à Munich.
Dans une brasserie du centre ville,
Hitler est installé à une table,
Mais ce n'est pas un client comme les autres.
Les services de renseignement militaires l'ont chargé,
D'espionner un groupuscule d'extrême droite,
Qui a établi ici son QG.
Il s'agit du DAP,
Le Parti ouvrier allemand,
Un groupuscule ultraradical d'une cinquantaine de membres.
La mission d'Adolf Hitler,
Exige de rester incognito,
Mais rien ne va se passer comme prévu.
Et c'est une phrase qui va le faire sortir de ses gonds.
Alors que les membres du parti débattent.
L'un d'entre eux,
Prône l'idée d'une Bavière indépendante,
Qui ferait sécession de l'Allemagne.
Impensable pour Hitler.
Piqué au vif.
Il ne peut s'empêcher de se lever.
Il monte sur la table,
Il prend la parole,
Et là,
Il fait un discours absolument fanatique,
Pour dénoncer le séparatisme bavarois.
Hitler défend la grande Allemagne,
Pour laquelle il s'est battu.
Et il fait preuve d'une telle ferveur,
D'une telle conviction,
Que tout l'auditoire est captivé.
Il réalise qu'il a quelque chose,
Un talent dont il n'avait jamais pris conscience avant.
Quand je parle, les gens m'écoutent.
Et soudain, c'est comme le paradis pour lui.
Il est entouré de gens qui pensent qu'il est formidable,
Qui l'accepte et qui l'écoute.
Cette soirée du 12 septembre 1919 marque un tournant,
Dans la vie d'Adolf Hitler.
C'est en fait la seconde précise,
Où la carrière politique d'Hitler démarre.
Adolf Hitler a trouvé sa voie.
Il sera homme politique.
Il adhère au DAP,
Dont il devient le cinquante cinquième membre.
Et le jeune militant ne compte pas s'arrêter là.
Son ambition désormais,
C'est de se hisser au sommet.
Deux ans plus tard,
Un soir de février 1921,
À Munich.
Le Circus Krone,
L'une des plus grandes salles de spectacle de la ville,
Est pleine à craquer.
6000 personnes sont là.
Elles sont venues écouter Adolf Hitler.
En quelques mois,
Le petit agitateur de brasserie,
Est devenu le porte parole vedette du parti.
Il remplit les salles sur son simple nom.
Militants et curieux accourent.
Séduits par son discours radical et ses talents d'orateur.
Il exprime la souffrance du peuple allemand.
Il exprime la rage et exprime la colère,
Il exprime la douleur,
Et ça aussi,
C'est quelque chose qui parle au public de l'époque.
Puis il arrive à créer des enthousiasme collectifs authentique,
Y compris avec des gens qui étaient venus avec l'idée de le chahuter.
Il faut dire que les discours d'Adolf Hitler,
C'est du jamais vu pour l'époque.
Dans les années 20,
Voici comment les politiques s'adressaient à leur auditoire.
Ton lancinant,
Académique,
Voix chevrotante.
Et voici maintenant un discours d'Adolf Hitler.
C'est nouveau pour l'époque.
On a encore jamais vu des gens,
Dans l'Allemagne de cette époque,
Prendre la parole de cette manière.
Hitler parle de manière hachée, de manière cassée.
Des phrases courtes,
Mais pleines de haine,
Pleines d'agressivité.
Ce qui nous, nous choque et nous paraît ridicule.
Ce ton d'adjudant chef,
A une signification et a une valeur à l'époque.
Hitler a pris conscience qu'il peut devenir bien plus,
Que l'orateur d'un groupuscule de Bavière.
Il est capable de soulever les foules.
Il peut jouer un rôle politique de premier plan.
Devenu incontournable au sein du DAP,
Il prend la tête du petit parti.
Mais désormais, il a une ambition immense.
Devenir un jour un leader national.
Pourquoi pas même le leader de toute l'Allemagne.
Pour se hisser au sommet du pouvoir dans les années 20,
Hitler va mettre en place une stratégie de communication ultramoderne.
Au delà de ses talents d'orateur et de l'extrémisme de ses idées,
Il va jouer sur un élément que peu de politiciens de son époque utilisent,
La force de l'image.
Et cela commence par sa propre apparence.
Regardez,
À la fin de la guerre, en 1918,
Il arborait de belles bacantes,
Comme on emportait au XIX siècle.
Quelques mois plus tard, il change de look,
Et se fait tailler la moustache en petite brosse.
C'est plutôt moderne pour l'époque.
Il y a aussi, je pense,
Sa volonté de couper avec le XIX siècle.
Il est très jeune et donc il y a des effets de mode,
Dans la jeunesse munichoise de son temps.
Il y a la coiffure gominée au départ sur les portraits,
Ensuite, il travaillera la mèche,
Mais dans un deuxième temps.
Et pour que personne n'oublie son visage,
Pour frapper les esprits,
Dans les années 20,
Hitler va travailler avec un spécialiste.
Il s'appelle Heinrich Hoffmann,
C'est un photographe professionnel,
Et c'est aussi un nazi convaincu.
Un des tout premiers adhérents du petit parti d'Hitler.
Il lui propose de devenir son photographe attitré.
Et Hitler accepte.
Il se laisse convaincre qu'il y a quelque chose à faire,
Et que son personnage peut être peut être stylisé.
C'est à Munich, dans le studio d'Heinrich Hoffmann,
Au 50 de la rue Schelling,
Qu'Hitler va apprendre à utiliser la photographie,
Comme un outil de communication.
Devant l'objectif,
Il va travailler ses gestes et son attitude,
Pour mieux capter l'attention, pour mieux convaincre.
Il met au point des gestuelles dramatiques,
Pour marteler ses idées,
Des attitudes théâtrales,
Qui lui donnent un style immédiatement reconnaissable,
Celui d'un homme habité par ses convictions.
Pour l'époque, c'est révolutionnaire.
Et auprès du public,
L'effet sera immédiat.
Ce qui le caractérise,
C'est la foi très forte qu'il a dans son dans son destin politique.
Vous pouviez être sûr que lorsqu'il prenait la parole,
Cela ferait des étincelles.
Hitler a très bien compris la logique des médias.
Il faut faire parler de soi.
S'il y a de la violence, peu importe.
Brusquement, Hitler fait irruption,
Secondé par ses SA,
Hitler tire un coup de revolver au plafond,
Et il annonce que la révolution nationale a commencé.
C'est à Munich,
Dans le studio d'Heinrich Hoffmann,
Au 50 de la rue Schelling,
Qu'Hitler va apprendre à utiliser la photographie,
Comme un outil de communication.
Devant l'objectif,
Il va travailler ses gestes et son attitude,
Pour mieux capter l'attention,
Pour mieux convaincre.
Il met au point des gestuelles dramatiques,
Pour marteler ses idées.
Des attitudes théâtrales qui lui donnent un style immédiatement reconnaissable,
Celui d'un homme habité par ses convictions.
Il n'est pas seulement un politique,
Il est un acteur qui vit intensément son rôle.
Son astuce, c'est de transférer le théâtre.
Il n'a jamais été formé comme acteur,
Mais il a passé des soirées entières au théâtre ou à l'opéra,
De transférer ça dans la politique.
Hitler joue au boxeur quand il se veut combatif,
Il brandit le poing pour menacer ses ennemis.
Il a tout essayé, en fait,
Mais la photo avant, il le faisait devant les glaces.
Là, la photo,
Il se rend mieux compte.
Il perfectionne son jeu de scène.
Et le jeu de scène,
Toute cette gestuelle,
Ça fait partie de l'influence qu'il exerce.
Son objectif est aussi de se différencier,
Des hommes politiques de son époque.
Voici comment un des présidents de la République allemande,
Le maréchal Hindenburg,
Intervenait en public.
Il lit son discours sans quitter son texte des yeux,
Sans faire de gestes,
Sans la moindre émotion.
Hitler, lui,
Fait tout le contraire.
Les poings serrés pour exprimer sa colère.
Le doigt vengeur pour désigner l'ennemi à abattre.
Il appuie chaque idée par des gestes outranciers,
Comme s'il était possédé par son discours.
À tel point qu'Hoffman,
Transformera plus tard certains clichés de travail,
En affiches de propagande tout aussi expressives.
Allure, diction, posture,
Hitler ne laisse rien au hasard.
Et ce travail qu'on appellerait aujourd'hui,
Du marketing politique,
Il va l'appliquer également à son parti.
Hitler trouve le logo du DAP bien fade,
Comparé à ceux de ses concurrents.
Car les grands partis de l'époque possèdent,
Des logos qui claquent,
Trois flèches pour les socialistes,
Les couleurs noir, blanc, rouge,
Du drapeau allemand pour la droite nationale.
La faucille et le marteau des communistes.
Hitler veut lui aussi un symbole qui frappe les esprits,
Et il veut faire mieux que ses concurrents.
Alors il va se mettre au travail.
Un soir de 1920,
Dans la brasserie qui lui sert de quartier général,
Il réunit la direction du DAP.
Chacun doit donner ses idées pour le futur logo du parti,
Et plusieurs symboles sont étudiés.
Une étoile à 8 branches,
Une autre à 6 branches,
Une sorte de croix arrondie et plusieurs autres.
Les idées vont bon train et la réunion est importante.
D'ailleurs, au bas du document,
Une phrase manuscrite affirme,
"Le dessin sacré des Allemands.
Un de ces dessins devra nous soulever."
Elle est signée Adolf Hitler.
Et parmi les différents croquis.
Hitler va jeter son dévolu sur celui ci.
Que l'on appelle une croix gammée.
Pour comprendre pourquoi,
Il faut se plonger dans l'univers mental de l'extrême droite allemande,
Qui l'a tant marqué.
Un univers pétri de mythologie germanique,
De combats dantesques pour la survie d'une race,
La race aryenne,
Qui serait menacée par d'autres civilisations.
Toute une littérature ultranationaliste,
Attribue un emblème à ce peuple,
Une croix gammée,
Symbole d'une prétendue supériorité de la race blanche nordique.
Il s'agit de revenir aux origines de l'Allemagne,
Aux origines de la civilisation nordique.
Ce signe,
C'est pour Hitler le symbole de la supériorité des Germains,
Sur tous les autres peuples et en particulier sur les Juifs.
"La Croix représente l'esprit aryen et non l'esprit juif.
C'est le signe de notre combat contre cette peste mondiale."
Cet emblème,
Hitler veut lui donner le plus de force possible,
Pour séduire les adhérents des autres partis.
Il vise d'abord les communistes,
Très populaires auprès des ouvriers.
Il va donc leur emprunter la couleur rouge de leur drapeau.
Mais il lorgne aussi sur ses concurrents à l'extrême droite.
Alors il va s'approprier le blanc,
De la bannière impériale allemande.
Ainsi né,
La marque de fabrique du parti hitlérien.
Dans la même veine,
Hitler rebaptise son groupuscule,
Pour tenter de ratisser plus large.
Le discret Parti des travailleurs allemands devient,
Le Parti des nationaux socialistes,
En abrégé le Parti nazi.
Hitler fait tout ce qu'il peut pour persuader ses partisans,
Que Parti des travailleurs allemands,
Ça ne fonctionnait pas.
Il manquait quelque chose.
Mais ce qui plaît aux gens,
Selon lui,
C'est d'associer le nationalisme et le socialisme.
Un an seulement après son entrée en politique,
Hitler s'est créé une image reconnaissable entre toutes.
Et son parti, avec ses croix gammée,
Est désormais facilement identifiable.
Reste maintenant à se faire connaître auprès de tous les Allemands.
Et pour cela,
Hitler va faire preuve d'un sens certain de la mise en scène.
Il crée sa milice personnelle,
Des gros bras qui seront chargés de rendre son parti bien visible,
Sur la scène politique et d'impressionner les foules.
Et il les dote d'un uniforme,
Des chemises brunes.
En réalité,
Il ne fait que copier un autre homme politique,
Qui a fait tout cela avant lui.
Le leader fasciste italien Mussolini,
Qui a pris le pouvoir à Rome avec ses troupes de chemises noires.
Et même le nom de sa milice, ne doit pas laisser indifférent.
Il les baptise SA,
Comme Sexion d'Assaut.
Grâce aux SA,
Les meeting d'Hitler se transforment en démonstrations de force.
Ses partisans,
Il les fait parader au pas cadencé avec une discipline,
Qui marque les esprits.
La mise en scène est telle,
Que lui, chef d'un petit parti,
Passe pour un homme politique de premier plan.
Il va même réussir à faire les gros titres des journaux allemands,
En utilisant une méthode simple,
Qui marchera quasiment à tous les coups.
La violence.
Un jour de septembre 1921,
Alors que la nuit est déjà tombée,
Hitler et sa milice investissent en force,
Une brasserie du centre de Munich.
Ce soir là, un parti d'extrême droite concurrent y tient un meeting.
L'objectif des nazis,
C'est de faire d'une pierre deux coups,
Empêcher la réunion et faire parler d'eux dans la presse.
Vous savez, ils ont ces grosses chopes de bière en Allemagne.
Et alors là ils frappent les gens.
Et cela devient vite une immense bagarre.
Et c'est alors que quelqu'un a coupé la lumière,
Ce qui n'a fait qu'augmenter l'atmosphère de violence.
Et quand la lumière est revenue, la bagarre a continué.
La réunion publique tourne au chaos.
La police doit intervenir.
Le chef du parti nazi est arrêté, mais aucune importance.
Ce qu'il espère avant tout,
C'est que les journaux parlent de lui.
Le lendemain, le 15 septembre 1921,
Dans Les Nouvelles de Munich,
En haut de page,
Un article rend compte de la réunion politique de la veille.
Mais au lieu de titrer sur le meeting du parti concurrent,
Le journal n'a retenu qu'une information,
Un raid national socialiste.
Le parti nazi a piqué la vedette à son rival.
"La réunion a été perturbée par un raid national socialiste mûrement préparé."
Le journal cite même le nom du meneur,
Adolf Hitler.
"Les nationaux socialistes ont réduit l'orateur au silence,
Pour donner la parole à Hitler."
Au total, le nom d'Hitler est répété 4 fois.
Ce premier coup d'éclat a atteint son but,
Faire parler de lui, quel qu'en soit le prix.
Hitler a très bien compris la logique des médias.
Il faut faire parler de soi.
Donc s'il y a de la violence,
Peu importe le fait que la police intervienne,
Que lui éventuellement soit interrogé pendant quelques heures,
Ou fréquente un commissariat de police,
Voire soit mis en prison 1 ou 2 jours.
Il faut qu'on parle de lui.
Puisque le coup de poing de la brasserie leur a assuré une nouvelle notoriété.
Hitler va pousser les SA,
À poursuivre sur la même voie.
Il leur ordonne de provoquer un maximum de bagarre.
Tous les prétextes sont bons.
Et plus les échauffourées sont spectaculaires,
Plus la presse parle des nazis.
La Journée allemande de Nuremberg.
Par exemple lors de la journée des nationalistes allemands à Nuremberg,
Ce quotidien rapporte que des porteurs de croix gammée,
Ont attaqué 3 personnes juives dans une voiture.
Une autre fois,
La presse s'inquiète de la terreur de la croix gammée,
Quand à Munich,
17 jeunes gens sont expulsés d'un café,
Et sont tabassés à coups de matraque et de bâtons.
Les S.A. vont jusqu'à commettre des attentats,
Comme cette grenade lancée sur la Bourse de Manheim,
Une petite ville de Bavière.
La publicité, c'était l'oxygène d'Hitler.
Vous pouvez être sûr que dès qu'Hitler parlait,
Cela ferait des étincelles.
Dans son discours,
Mais aussi dans la salle avec des bagarres.
Et ainsi la presse en parlait.
Plus d'une semaine ne passe,
Sans que les nazis ne fassent parler d'eux.
Et le discours ultranationaliste d'Hitler,
S'entend désormais dans toute l'Allemagne.
En 1923, il a multiplié le nombre de ses adhérents par 10.
Son parti compte 55 000 membres.
Hitler se sent plus fort que jamais.
Alors il décide de s'appuyer sur ses 800 S.A.
Pour organiser un putsch et marcher sur la capitale,
Berlin.
Le 8 novembre vers 19h,
Et avec plusieurs centaines d'hommes armés,
Il prend en otage une partie du gouvernement,
Qui était en meeting dans une grande salle munichoise.
Le pouvoir,
Il veut s'en emparer par la force.
Et brusquement,
Hitler fait irruption,
Secondé par ses S.A.,
Et Hitler tire un coup de revolver au plafond.
Hitler se propulse à la tribune et il annonce là,
Que la révolution nationale a commencé.
Hitler exige des ministres présents,
Qu'ils s'associent à lui,
Pour instaurer une dictature et marcher sur Berlin.
Mais les putschistes d'Hitler ont surestimé leur force,
Face à eux,
L'armée et la police sont mieux armées, mieux organisées.
Pendant 2 jours,
Les affrontements font rage dans les rues.
Les nazis ne font pas le poids.
La tentative de putsch est écrasée.
Hitler est arrêté,
Jugé et condamné pour haute trahison.
Son ascension semble se briser net,
Mais ce n'est qu'une apparence.
Car il en est certain, bientôt,
Il dirigera l'Allemagne.
Il a déjà une nouvelle stratégie en tête.
Ce qui le caractérise,
C'est effectivement la foi très forte qu'il a dans son destin politique.
Au delà de tout ce qui est imaginable.
Dans la prison de Landsberg,
En ce mois d'avril 1924,
Le crépitement d'une machine à écrire se fait entendre,
Depuis une cellule à l'étage.
Adolf Hitler fait taper des dizaines de pages,
Par un compagnon de captivité.
Il s'est lancé dans un projet qui lui donne une nouvelle énergie.
Rédiger un livre pour expliquer sa pensée politique.
Il l'intitulera Mein Kampf, mon combat.
Mein Kampf est la matrice d'un programme politique.
Hitler se veut le porte parole de tous les anciens combattants,
D'ailleurs, le titre le dit,
Mon combat.
Alors, il aurait pu l'appeler Notre combat,
mais il veut bien montrer,
Qu'il est celui qui est prêt à aller jusqu'au bout,
À tirer toutes les conséquences de la nécessité de combattre pour l'Allemagne.
Derrière les barreaux,
Hitler n'a pas renoncé à la conquête du pouvoir.
Il a juste changé de stratégie.
Car l'échec de sa tentative de coup d'État,
L'a fait réfléchir.
Il veut désormais arriver au sommet de l'État légalement.
Par la voie des urnes.
Il veut gagner les élections.
L'objectif d'Hitler, avec Mein Kampf,
C'est de se faire reconnaître comme le chef incontesté,
De la droite nationaliste.
Un gros livre,
Un essai politique de plus de 600 pages,
Mais un essai monstrueux.
Où il développe son idéologie ultra nationaliste,
Et les thèses racistes qu'il échafaude depuis les années 20.
Il insiste en particulier sur la prétendue,
Supériorité des Aryens sur les Juifs,
Jugeant ces derniers responsables de tous les malheurs de l'Allemagne.
Il compare la religion juive à une maladie vénérienne,
La syphilis.
L'effet produit par sa présence est celui des plantes parasites.
Là où il se fixe,
Le peuple qui l'accueille s'éteint au bout de plus ou moins longtemps.
Hitler est explicite dans Mein Kampf sur son idée,
Que le territoire qui sera dominé par l'Allemagne,
Devra être un territoire sans juifs.
Hitler promet également une Allemagne dominatrice.
Son modèle,
C'est le grand empire germanique,
Celui qui,
Avant la Première Guerre mondiale,
S'étendait sur une grande partie de l'Europe.
"Notre but :
Assurer au peuple allemand le territoire qui lui revient en ce monde."
Et ce territoire,
Il est gigantesque.
Car Hitler convoite tous les pays,
Où se trouvent des populations d'origine allemande.
L'autriche,
La Hongrie,
La Tchécoslovaquie,
La Pologne.
Et au nom de la supériorité de la race aryenne,
Il vise même jusqu'à la Russie.
Il s'agit de faire comprendre pourquoi il se bat,
Et le livre débouche sur la vision d'une nouvelle guerre,
Sur la conquête de l'espace vital.
Et de ce point de vue,
Il s'agit de faire comprendre que le combat du présent,
N'est que la préparation de la guerre à venir.
Sa pensée politique est prête.
Son livre va lui servir de base,
Pour les campagnes électorales à venir.
Dès qu'il sera libre,
Hitler va repartir à l'assaut de l'Allemagne,
Et cette fois-ci,
Plus rien ne l'arrêtera.
Nous sommes le 20 décembre 1924,
Hitler sort de prison.
Pour conquérir le pouvoir par les urnes,
Il voit grand.
Il veut faire campagne dans tout le pays,
Convaincre chaque électeur de voter pour lui.
Mais pour cela, il lui faut beaucoup d'argent.
Et son parti n'a plus un sou.
Ils étaient très pauvres.
C'est un de ses lieutenants,
Qui avait dit très souvent,
Quand on allait annoncer un discours destiné à transformer le monde,
On n'avait pas de quoi se payer la colle pour les affiches.
Alors Hitler doit absolument trouver de l'argent,
Beaucoup d'argent.
Pour cela, il n'y a qu'un seul moyen.
Il lui faut le soutien des grandes fortunes allemandes.
Et à l'aube des années 30,
Il y a quelques grands patrons très riches en Allemagne.
Ce sont en particulier les magnats de la sidérurgie,
Les propriétaires des usines de charbon,
Et d'acier de la Ruhr.
L'ennui, c'est qu'aux yeux de ces grands patrons,
Hitler reste un extrémiste politique,
Un homme pas franchement rassurant pour le business.
Hitler, déjà,
A un programme politique très ambigu.
Déjà le nom de son Parti, national socialiste.
Alors national, évidemment,
Les élites traditionnelles sont plutôt nationalistes.
Mais il y a quand même le mot socialiste aussi dans son parti,
Et avec un programme économique assez flou,
Très contradictoire.
On ne sait pas très bien finalement,
Quel va être le sort de l'économie de marché,
Des entreprises privées.
Si le leader nazi ne trouve pas de fonds pour faire redécoller son parti,
Il peut dire adieu à ses ambitions de pouvoir.
Alors, pour séduire les patrons,
Hitler va ruser.
Il ne va pas les démarcher lui même.
Il va trouver un intermédiaire plus rassurant,
Un homme qui va gagner leur confiance et leurs comptes en banque.
Nous sommes le 2 novembre 1927,
Dans la Thierschstrasseà Munich,
Hitler habite ici,
Au numéro 41.
Et ce jour là,
Il a donné rendez-vous à un fidèle de la première heure.
Son nom Hermann Goering.
Goering est une star de la Grande Guerre,
Un as de l'aviation allemande,
Bardé de décorations,
Un pilote de chasse très populaire en Allemagne et aussi un nazi convaincu.
Mais surtout,
Goering possède un carnet d'adresses bien rempli.
Sa notoriété lui a permis, après la guerre,
De se reconvertir dans les affaires.
Il fréquente de près les grands patrons allemands.
C'est donc à lui, qu'Hitler,
Confie la mission de les séduire.
Donc là,
Goering est chargé effectivement de procurer de l'argent aux parti,
Donc d'approcher les industriels.
Et c'est là que ça commence.
Goering comprend vite qu'il faut rassurer les patrons.
À la différence d'Hitler,
Il sait comment s'y prendre pour leur inspirer confiance.
À la manière d'un bon comédien,
Il va soigner sa mise en scène et leur en mettre plein les yeux.
Il retrouve un autre ancien copain qui s'appelait,
Qui était un petit monsieur tout chafouin,
Mais qui avait fait un bel héritage,
Et qui donc avait les moyens.
Mais surtout, il avait une belle Mercedes.
Et ça, pour les affaires, c'était merveilleux.
Parce qu'il déguise son copain en chauffeur,
Et lui se rend chez les clients avec sa belle Mercedes.
Et le chauffeur en livrée,
Qui était le propriétaire de la Mercedes.
Ils n'étaient pas forcé de le savoir.
Et ça impressionne.
Et pour faire cracher les patrons au bassinet,
Goering a préparé ses arguments.
Il promet des contrats mirifiques avec le futur État hitlérien,
Des millions de mark,
Qui feront tourner leurs usines et remplir les carnets de commandes.
Il s'appuie d'ailleurs sur Mein Kampf, le livre de Hitler.
N'y est-il pas écrit noir sur blanc,
Que pour construire la grande Allemagne,
L'Etat nazi aura pour priorité de réarmer le pays.
"Nous voulons retrouver des armes !" écrivait-il.
Et Goering sait se faire pressant.
Les premiers qui rejoindront notre parti,
On ne les oubliera pas quand on sera au pouvoir,
Et que nous aurons de très gros contrats à offrir à ce moment là.
Parce que l'Allemagne va réarmer, etc.
Dépêchez-vous, il y en aura pas pour tout le monde.
Alléchés par la perspective de gros contrats.
Certains grands patrons se laisse convaincre.
Et pas n'importe lesquels.
Par exemple, Fritz Thyssen,
Le magnat de la sidérurgie.
Il tombe sous le charme de Goering,
Alors que jusqu'ici,
Il s'était toujours refusé à Hitler.
Thyssen mise sur Goering,
En disant bon son parti,
Tout le monde se méfiait de son parti,
Mais si Goering est dedans et s'y intéresse,
On peut miser dessus.
Et Thyssen va jouer un rôle déterminant,
Dans l'ascension du parti nazi.
Il ouvre grand son chéquier,
À un moment où Hitler en a vraiment besoin.
Nous avons retrouvé un document qui le prouve.
En septembre 1945,
Lors d'un interrogatoire mené par les Américains,
Thyssen reconnaît avoir soutenu financièrement les nazis,
En contribuant en 1927,
À l'achat du siège du parti,
La Maison brune.
Fini les arrière salles de brasserie.
Hitler dispose enfin d'un bâtiment qui en impose,
Un hôtel particulier, cossu,
Avec de vastes salles lumineuses.
Et à l'étage,
Son bureau personnel,
Thissen s'est vraiment montrer généreux.
J'ai dû payer, dira t'il,
Sur mes propres deniers, entre 200 et 280 000 marks.
Et Thyssen ne s'est pas arrêté là.
Il reconnaît avoir versé aux nazis,
Pour leurs dépenses courantes,
20 000 marks tous les ans,
À compter de 1932.
"J'ai donné au parti, dit il,
Une belle petite somme de 20 000 marks,
Qui est devenue par la suite une contribution,
À verser chaque année."
Grâce à Goering,
Adolf Hitler dispose désormais d'un budget confortable.
Il peut financer les campagnes électorales,
Les plus mégalomaniaques jamais vu en Allemagne.
Il organise d'immenses rassemblements
dans la petite ville de Nuremberg.
Il s'offre également une tournée dans toute l'Allemagne,
Et ne se déplace plus qu'en avion.
Un atout capital qui lui permet de tenir jusqu'à 3 meetings dans la même journée,
Là ou ses concurrents se contentent d'un seul.
C'est le premier homme politique à utiliser cela,
Ce qui donne d'ailleurs à sa personnalité une espèce d'aura, d'ubiquité.
Il paraît un peu magique comme ça,
De pouvoir être présent partout en Allemagne,
Au même moment.
Le leader nazi en tire même des affiches de propagande,
Aux slogans grandiloquents.
"Hitler domine l'Allemagne."
Ses meetings ont de plus en plus de retentissement.
La foule s'y presse plus nombreuse de mois en mois.
L'ascension du parti nazi,
Semble désormais irrésistible.
Pourquoi on le croit, lui ?
Parce qu'on ne croit plus dans les autres.
Certaines entreprises vont aller jusqu'à participer,
Au crime de l'assassinat des juifs d'Europe.
Les détenus qui ne sont plus aptes au travail sont acheminés,
Vers le camp d'Auschwitz-Birkenau,
Où se trouvent les installations de gazage pour y être exterminés.
Je fais le serment de sortir de cet enfer,
De laisser de côté même le deuil,
Et de tenir quoi qu'il arrive.
Grâce à Goering,
Adolf Hitler dispose désormais d'un budget confortable,
Et peut financer les campagnes électorales,
Les plus mégalomaniaques jamais vues en Allemagne.
Il organise d'immenses rassemblements dans la petite ville de Nuremberg.
Il s'offre également une tournée dans toute l'Allemagne,
Et ne se déplace plus qu'en avion.
Un atout capital qui lui permet de tenir jusqu'à 3 meetings dans la journée.
Là où ses concurrents se contentent d'un seul.
C'est le premier homme politique à utiliser cela,
Ce qui donne d'ailleurs à sa personnalité une espèce d'aura, d'ubiquité.
Il paraît un peu magique comme ça de pouvoir,
Être présent partout en Allemagne au même moment.
Le leader nazi en tire même des affiches de propagande,
Aux slogans grandiloquents,
"Hitler domine l'Allemagne."
Ses meetings ont de plus en plus de retentissement.
La foule s'y presse plus nombreuses de mois en mois.
L'ascension du parti nazi semble irrésistible.
Il faut dire que les circonstances lui sont de plus en plus favorables.
Car en 1929, la Grande Dépression frappe l'Allemagne.
Une crise économique sans précédent.
Le chômage atteint des niveaux records,
L'inflation explose,
Le pays est au bord du gouffre.
Alors pour de plus en plus d'Allemands,
Hitler apparaît désormais comme un espoir,
Une alternative face aux vieux partis traditionnels,
Qui n'ont pas su redresser le pays.
Pourquoi on le croit, lui ?
Pourquoi il apparaît comme un homme politique traditionnel ?
Parce qu'on ne croit plus dans les autres,
Parce qu'il a été en prison.
Il est différent,
Il a été rejeté.
Et puis, parce qu'il a l'air sincère, authentique,
De parler vrai.
Au centre de ses meetings,
Un slogan qui va toucher le cœur des électeurs allemands c'est,
"Allemagne, réveille toi !"
Il y a toute une mise en scène de la de la résurrection de l'Allemagne.
C'est ça que ça doit symboliser.
Chaque fois, c'est d'ailleurs l'un des slogans de campagne,
Du début des années 30,
C'est Allemagne, réveille toi !
Cette stratégie qui permet au parti nazi de voir ses scores grimper en flèche,
Élection après élection.
Alors qu'il culminait à 3% des voix à la fin des années 20.
En quelques années, il passe à 18%,
Puis à plus de 33% des suffrages.
Il devient le premier parti d'Allemagne.
Et le 30 janvier 1933, Adolf Hitler atteint son objectif.
Il est nommé chef du gouvernement.
Le petit agitateur de Bavière,
Est devenu en 10 ans,
L'homme le plus puissant d'Allemagne.
Dès qu'il arrive au pouvoir,
Adolf Hitler n'a qu'une obsession,
Faire de l'Allemagne la plus grande puissance du continent.
Et pour cela, il va prendre une décision radicale.
Transformer son pays en un immense chantier.
Désormais, d'un bout à l'autre du Reich,
Voilà ce que l'on voit.
Des constructions à perte de vue,
Des centaines de kilomètres d'autoroutes,
Des lignes de chemin de fer.
Et surtout des armes.
Chars ultramodernes,
Canons dernière génération,
Bombardiers surpuissants.
Les usines du troisième Reich tournent à plein régime.
Faire de l'Allemagne une très grande puissance,
Et la plus grande du continent européen.
Cela lui tient beaucoup à cœur.
Sans politique de grands travaux, pas de grande Allemagne.
Hitler peut ainsi afficher sa puissance.
Mais ces travaux pharaoniques,
Ne servent pas les seuls intérêts du Führer.
Car ces immenses chantiers font aussi les affaires,
Des grandes entreprises allemandes.
Elles s'appellent Siemens, Krupp,
Thyssen,
Ou encore I.G.Farben.
De grands groupes,
Qui ont porté Hitler au pouvoir.
De grands groupes qui peuvent maintenant espérer,
Amasser des fortunes considérables.
Cette politique de grands travaux représente des marchés énormes,
Et engendre donc des profits colossaux.
Donc les entreprises sont extrêmement intéressées,
On peut même dire sont achetées par le régime.
Ainsi pendant plus de 10 ans,
À partir de 1933,
Les grandes entreprises du pays vont connaître un essor considérable.
Il faut dire que pour elle, désormais,
Les commandes de l'État représentent beaucoup.
Alors certaines ne vont reculer devant rien,
Pour gagner toujours plus d'argent.
Quitte à prendre part aux plus effroyables projets d'Adolf Hitler,
L'extermination des juifs d'Europe.
Certaines entreprises allemandes,
Au nom du profit,
Du patriotisme,
Mettent le doigt dans un engrenage,
Qui va mener certaines à la participation très directe,
À l'**** des juifs.
Cela peut paraître complètement fou aujourd'hui,
70 ans après les faits.
Et pourtant,
C'est bien dans cette spirale insensée,
Que certaines entreprises vont se lancer.
Parmi elles, l'une des plus grandes au monde.
Son siège, ultramoderne à l'époque,
Se trouve à Francfort.
Son nom,
I.G.Farben.
Un géant de la chimie,
Qui va se retrouver piégé par sa quête absolue de profits.
I.G.Farben a été impliqué et complice de la solution finale,
Dès le moment où celle ci a été mise en œuvre.
I.G.Farben n'a pas pratiqué elle même l'extermination,
Mais l'I.G.Farben a fonctionné grâce à cette extermination.
On peut donc estimer que ces responsables,
Sont indiscutablement coupables,
Et peut être,
Aussi coupables que les responsables nazis.
Une histoire folle et qui fait froid dans le dos.
Une histoire qui commence dès l'année 1933.
À cette époque,
Adolf Hitler vient d'arriver au pouvoir,
Et il rêve déjà d'agrandir l'espace vital de l'Allemagne.
Une conquête qui passera forcément par la guerre.
Or, pour mener cette guerre,
Le Führer le sait déjà,
Il va devoir faire face à un problème majeur.
Hitler a l'expérience de la Première Guerre mondiale,
Où l'Allemagne s'est retrouvée confrontée au blocus britannique,
Et au fait qu'ils ont eu un certain nombre de pénuries,
De matières premières et de sources d'énergie.
Donc Hitler veut vraiment assurer son indépendance.
Car pour Hitler, ça ne fait aucun doute.
Un nouvel embargo est à prévoir.
Dès qu'il entrera en guerre,
Son pays va de nouveau manquer de matières premières essentielles,
Pour son armée.
Il ne pourra alors plus compter sur le caoutchouc,
Qu'il achète à l'Indochine,
Pour fabriquer les pneus de ses avions.
Il ne pourra pas non plus importer de pétrole,
Pour alimenter en essence ses chars et ses bombardiers.
Il en avait évidemment besoin pour sa guerre éclair.
Si vous voulez mobiliser rapidement vos forces pour attaquer un pays,
Vous devez avoir des camions qui utilisent de l'essence,
Des tanks qui utilisent eux aussi de l'essence.
Mais ces véhicules se déplacent grâce à des roues produites en caoutchouc,
Tous ces produits sont donc militairement indispensables.
Sans essence et sans caoutchouc,
Plus rien n'est donc possible pour Hitler.
Il peut dire adieu à son rêve d'une grande Allemagne.
Il lui faut de toute urgence une solution.
Or, cette solution,
Elle va lui être apportée de toutes pièces par une entreprise.
Une entreprise qui n'est autre que le géant I.G.Farben.
I.G.Farben était spécialisée dans la fabrication de produits chimiques,
Qui auparavant étaient issus de matières premières naturelles.
C'était la plus grande entreprise au monde,
De produits chimiques.
Et parmi les dernières découvertes de l'entreprise,
Il y en a justement deux qui peuvent s'avérer,
Extrêmement précieuses pour le Führer.
Les chimistes d'I.G.Farben,
Ont réussi à mettre au point de l'essence de synthèse,
Dans ces laboratoires,
En se passant totalement de pétrole naturel.
Et ce n'est pas tout.
Une autre invention majeure est née ici,
Celle du caoutchouc,
Entièrement artificiel,
Du caoutchouc, là aussi, de synthèse.
I.G.Farben,
Est sur cette production de caoutchouc synthétique,
La seule entreprise qui détient en Allemagne,
Et même dans le monde, le procédé.
Et donc là, effectivement,
Si ça ne passe pas par d'I.G.Farben,
Ça ne pourra pas se faire.
Alors Hitler va faire une proposition en or à I.G.Farben,
Concernant ces découvertes.
Une proposition qui peut,
Du jour au lendemain,
Assurer la fortune de l'entreprise.
Ils ont donc signé 2 énormes deals,
Un sur le pétrole dès 1933,
Et un sur le caoutchouc 2 ans plus tard.
I.G.Farben construit alors d'énormes sites industriels,
Pour pouvoir fournir le pétrole et le caoutchouc nécessaires.
Et en 1939,
Hitler est enfin prêt pour partir en guerre.
Le 1ᵉʳ septembre, il envahit la Pologne.
Ensuite, il multiplie les victoires.
La Belgique, les Pays-Bas,
Le Luxembourg,
Puis la France ont conquis.
Les usines d'I.G.Farben tournent alors à plein régime.
Mais le problème,
C'est qu'elles vont se révéler insuffisantes,
Pour répondre à tous les besoins militaires.
Car l'ambition d'Hitler ne se limite pas à l'Europe de l'Ouest,
Il veut conquérir l'ensemble du continent,
Et mettre la main sur, rien de moins,
Que l'Union soviétique.
L'Est représente l'espace vital,
Qu'il a toujours souhaité conquérir,
Depuis le milieu des années 20,
Représente également le foyer du communisme,
Qu'il considère comme le danger mondial majeur.
Avec le projet d'invasion de la Russie,
Hitler s'apprête à déclencher,
L'une des plus grandes opérations militaires de l'histoire.
Il prévoit d'envoyer 4 millions de soldats,
Et pas moins de 600 000 véhicules.
C'est à dire 600 000 tanks ou camions,
Pour lesquels il faudra du pétrole et aussi du caoutchouc.
Le problème,
C'est que les quantités de caoutchouc,
Fournies par les usines d'I.G.Farben ne suffiront pas.
Mais les hommes d'Hitler,
Ont une solution pour l'entreprise.
Les autorités militaires allemandes,
Ont commencé à faire pression sur I.G.Farben,
Pour qu'elle construise une autre usine,
Quelque part à l'Est.
Une usine quelque part à l'Est,
Proche du futur front russe,
Comme l'exigent les Allemands.
Mais où exactement ?
Voilà toute la question.
Et elle repose sur les épaules d'un homme.
Il s'agit d'un des plus hauts dirigeants I.G.Farben,
Son nom,
Otto Ambros,
un ingénieur de 40 ans pour qui la réussite de cette usine,
Est un enjeu majeur pour sa carrière.
Il est très ambitieux.
C'est sa chance de prendre ses marques,
De montrer ce qu'il peut faire dans l'entreprise.
C'est son bébé technologique.
Et donc c'est à lui qu'on va confier la mission de trouver un site,
Pour l'usine.
Le 18 décembre 1940,
Otto Ambros part pour la Pologne.
Direction la Silésie,
Une région qu'il va arpenter d'un bout à l'autre,
À la recherche du meilleur emplacement.
Et le terrain est loin d'être facile à trouver,
Car il doit répondre à des critères très précis,
Comme par exemple être proche d'une ligne de chemin de fer,
Pour le transport de matériaux.
Et ce n'est pas tout.
Ça doit être un grand terrain plat.
Ou alors un terrain qu'on peut aplanir facilement.
Et puis,
Ça doit aussi se trouver près des matières premières indispensables,
Comme le charbon,
Qui est vraiment la base,
Et l'eau.
Après un mois de recherches,
Otto Ambros et ses hommes,
Vont trouver un emplacement qui remplit à merveille,
Toutes ces conditions.
Un terrain plat et immense,
Un terrain qui se trouve à proximité d'une rivière,
Et d'une ligne de chemin de fer.
Maintenant qu'ils ont le site,
Toute la question est de savoir comment ils vont construire l'usine.
Or, le site qu'ils ont prévu est gigantesque.
Voici les plans de l'époque,
Élaborés par les équipes d'I.G.Farben.
Une dizaine de bâtiments qui s'étendent sur plus de 20 kilomètres carrés.
Pour bâtir un tel site,
Il faut une main d'œuvre considérable.
30 000 ouvriers,
Sont nécessaires.
À priori, impossible d'en trouver autant.
Sauf que le terrain d'I.G.Farben ne se trouve pas n'importe où,
En Pologne.
Il est juste à côté d'un lieu,
Où il y a une main d'oeuvre toute trouvée.
Une main d'oeuvre corvéable à merci.
À Auschwitz,
Le camp d'Auschwitz.
Dans ce camp de concentration,
Au début 41,
Sont déportés des opposants politiques,
Des résistants,
Des intellectuels,
Et des juifs.
Leurs conditions de détention sont inhumaines.
Les prisonniers meurent de faim,
Ils sont battus à mort ou torturés.
Un système de terreur,
Où les détenus sont soumis au travail forcé,
Et réduits à l'esclavage.
Et c'est précisément cette main d'œuvre,
Qu'I.G.Farben va utiliser pour construire son usine.
Voici le compte rendu du contrat,
Que l'entreprise a passé avec les SS.
Un document qui date du 27 mars 41.
Il y est stipulé que chaque déporté sera facturé,
Entre 3 et 4 marks par jour à I.G.Farben.
En échange,
Cette main d'œuvre peut être exploitée sans limite.
C'est même ce que recommandent,
Très précisément,
Les responsables nazis à ceux de l'entreprise.
Ils disent à I.G.Farben,
Allez-y,
Utiliser cette main d'œuvre comme bon vous semble,
Sans vous soucier des conditions de travail.
Vous êtes exempté de toute limitation,
Comme par exemple sur le nombre d'heures de travail par jour.
Ils disent vous ne devez jamais ralentir le chantier,
Sous prétexte que cela aurait un impact sur le bien être des ouvriers.
C'est un document remarquable.
Vous pouvez les faire travailler aussi longtemps que vous le souhaitez.
Donc ils savaient à ce moment là qu'ils avaient carte blanche.
Ainsi, dès le printemps 41,
Plusieurs milliers de déportés d'Auschwitz sont réquisitionnés,
Pour aller participer à la construction de l'usine,
Qui se trouve à 5km du camp de concentration.
Pour les superviser,
Il y a bien sûr les SS,
Mais aussi des cadres d'I.G.Farben,
Qui assistent sans bouger,
Aux conditions terrifiantes auxquelles sont soumis les détenus.
Les SS exerçaient une grande violence à l'égard des prisonniers.
Les cadres d'I.G.Farben le voyaient parfaitement bien.
Notamment quand les travailleurs effectuaient,
Des allers-retours sur le chantier.
Ils étaient régulièrement battus par les SS.
Ils ne peuvent pas dire qu'ils ne savaient pas.
Ils sont soumis à une discipline extrêmement rigoureuse,
Sur le chantier et donc un détenu peut être battu,
Y compris à mort sur le chantier,
La plupart du temps par les kapos.
Pendant près d'un an,
Les cadres d'I.G.Farben vont ainsi pousser à bout,
Les prisonniers qui travaillent sur le site de l'usine.
Mais en exploitant cette main d'oeuvre de déportés,
Ils vont être entraînés bien plus loin,
Que ce qu'ils imaginaient.
Car en pactisant avec le régime nazi,
L'entreprise va s'engouffrer dans une spirale infernale,
Celle du projet le plus fou d'Adolf Hitler.
La solution finale,
L'extermination des juifs.
Ce matin du 10 octobre 1943,
Un train entre en gare de Auschwitz.
À l'intérieur, 1000 prisonniers,
Entassés depuis 3 jours dans des wagons à bestiaux.
Parmi eux, un jeune homme de 21 ans.
Il s'appelle Charles Parent.
Il a été arrêté en France avec sa mère et sa sœur.
Aujourd'hui,
Charles a 92 ans,
Et le souvenir de son arrivée à Auschwitz,
Reste toujours aussi présent.
Les aboiements,
Les cris.
On nous arrache des wagons,
On descend,
On nous oblige à nous ranger par cinq.
Nous avons l'impression d'être arrivés en enfer quelque part.
Sur le quai,
Charles et les autres déportés sont séparés en deux groupes,
Par les SS.
Charles est envoyé vers un rang,
Sa mère et sa sœur vers un autre.
Avec elles, il y a beaucoup d'autres femmes,
D'enfants et de personnes âgées.
Elles sont alors dirigées vers un endroit inconnu.
Charles demandera plus tard à d'autres détenus,
Où ont pu passer ses proches.
Il y a ce moment,
Presque indicible,
Où nous interrogeons les anciens.
Est-ce qu'on peut savoir,
Où sont partis les autres ?
Ceux qui ne sont pas avec nous.
Et pour toute réponse, ils lèvent l'index vers le ciel.
On a du mal à comprendre.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ?
Charles découvre l'horreur.
Auschwitz n'est plus seulement un camp de concentration,
Il s'agit d'une impitoyable machine,
À tuer.
Les nazis ont agrandi le site.
En plus du camp initial,
Il y a désormais celui de Birkenau.
Auschwitz Birkenau, un lieu d'extermination.
Où la mort est industrialisée.
Les déportés les plus fragiles,
Femmes, enfants, personnes âgées,
Sont systématiquement envoyés dans les salles comme celles ci.
Les SS leur font croire que ce sont des douches.
Ce sont en fait des chambres à gaz.
Des granulés de Zyklon B,
Un pesticide mortel,
Sont alors jetés par des trappes depuis le plafond.
La **** survient en quelques minutes.
La vérité s'incruste en nous.
Est-ce que c'est possible,
Que ces gens qu'on a laissés sur le quai, les nôtres !
Soit déjà gazés.
Et leur corps en train de brûler.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire ?
Comment recevoir cette information ?
Comment réagir ?
Pour certains, c'est l'effondrement.
Pour d'autres,
Je dois le dire,
C'est le serment de sortir de cet enfer,
De laisser de côté même le deuil.
Et de tenir quoi qu'il arrive.
Charles fait partie des déportés les plus robustes.
Alors il a été sélectionné pour être utilisé comme main d'œuvre,
Pour I.G.Farben.
Il va être envoyé sur un troisième site,
Buna Monowitz,
Qui se trouve à deux pas de l'usine.
Un camp de concentration spécialement construit pour I.G.Farben,
Il y a quelques mois.
À son arrivée, le jeune homme ainsi que les autres déportés,
Sont réunis dans le camp pour un discours d'accueil.
Un SS prend la parole.
Ce qu'il dit est glaçant.
Charles a gardé en tête chacun des mots qu'il a prononcés.
Vous êtes ici dans ce camp,
Dont je suis le chef.
Dont vous ne devrait pas sortir vivant.
Si vous désobéissez,
C'est la mort !
Si vous ne vous tenez pas propre,
C'est la ****.
Si vous chaparder,
Et un ordre tout à fait inattendu arrive,
Déshabillez-vous !
Le 10 octobre 1943,
Au fin fond de la Silésie, j'ai froid.
On nous rase la tête,
Sous les bras, entre les jambes.
Nous changeons de nature.
Le numéro devient notre nom.
Nous n'avons même plus le droit de prononcer notre nom.
Désormais,
Le quotidien de Charles sera de travailler à la construction,
De la future usine de caoutchouc.
Le chantier est titanesque.
Charles et une centaine de déportés,
Doivent creuser les fondations d'un immense bâtiment.
Un travail harassant,
Qu'ils effectuent près de 12h par jour,
Sans la moindre pause et quasiment rien à manger.
Chaque détenu reçoit, dans le meilleur des cas,
Une ration entre 800 et 1500 calories par jour,
Qui correspond pour l'essentiel à une soupe.
Cela signifie une perte de poids de 2 à 4 kg par semaine en moyenne.
Dans ces conditions,
Même un homme bien portant ne peut espérer survivre,
Plus de 3 mois dans le camp.
Charles voit ses compagnons s'effondrer,
Les uns après les autres.
Sur les 260 hommes de son groupe,
Qui comme lui,
Avaient été sélectionnés pour aller à Buna Monowitz.
Seuls 75 ont survécu.
Les autres sont morts d'épuisement,
Moins de 2 mois seulement après leur arrivée.
L'effondrement des déportés,
Ne fait pas les affaires d'I.G.Farben,
Car le chantier n'avance pas à la cadence souhaitée.
Alors l'entreprise ne veut plus avoir,
Que des détenus vaillants.
Désormais,
Au sein même du camp,
Les nazis mettent en place des sélections parmi les prisonniers.
Les plus faibles sont écartés,
Ce qui signifie la mort.
Les détenus qui ne sont plus aptes au travail,
Et qui sont donc sélectionnés,
Quittent le camp de Buna Monowitz,
et sont acheminés vers le camp d'Auschwitz-Birkenau,
Où se trouvent les installations de gazage pour y être exterminés.
Charles va lui aussi être confronté au processus de sélection.
Cela fait des mois qu'il travaille dans le camp.
Il a perdu plus de 20 kg.
Alors il a été désigné pour être écarté.
Arrive 2 SS,
Le doyen de l'infirmerie,
Et on nous fait tous déshabiller,
Et on doit défiler devant les SS,
Qui retiennent leur quota.
Le quota de gens qui vont mourir.
Et ils retiennent 36 détenus sur les 200 et quelque,
Qu'on est dans le bloc.
Et parmi les 36, il y a moi.
Comment faire pour sauver sa peau ?
L'homme qui note la liste des condamnés à ****,
Ne lui est pas inconnu.
Charles l'a rencontré il y a quelques semaines.
Il lui a même raconté une blague qui l'a fait rire.
Mais est-ce qu'il va le reconnaître ?
Monsieur le doyen lève les yeux vers moi,
Me regarde et me demande en allemand,
Si je connais beaucoup de blagues.
Je le regarde dans les yeux et je lui dis,
Je peux t'en raconter jusqu'à la fin de la guerre.
Et on reste 2 secondes les yeux dans les yeux.
Et tout à coup, il me dit,
Sors par l'autre porte.
Et j'ai une fois de plus sauvé ma vie.
Les 35 camarades, sont évidemment partis,
On ne les a jamais revu.
Charles a échappé à la ****,
Mais 25 000 déportés sont morts sur ce chantier.
Sacrifiés pour la construction d'une usine,
Qui n'a jamais vu le jour.
Seule la libération du camp par les troupes soviétiques,
Le 27 janvier 1945,
Mettra fin à l'horreur d'Auschwitz et à la fuite en avant,
D'I.G.Farben.
Aucun caoutchouc ne sera jamais produit,
Aucun carburant synthétique ne sera jamais produit.
Et quand les Russes arriveront en janvier 1945,
I.G aura connu d'énormes pertes.
Après la capitulation allemande en 1945,
La justice internationale cherche à condamner les responsables,
De l'extermination des Juifs.
Une cour internationale à Nuremberg est mise en place.
Pour la première fois, on parle de crimes contre l'humanité.
Adolf Hitler ne rendra jamais aucun compte.
Il s'est **** le 30 avril 45.
À Nuremberg, 24 hauts responsables nazis sont jugés.
La moitié sera condamnée à mort par pendaison.
Quant aux dirigeants d'I.G.Farben, une vingtaine,
Se retrouve sur le banc des accusés,
Dont le premier d'entre eux,
Otto Ambros.
Il plaide qu'il ignorait le sort,
Qui était réservé aux déportés qui travaillaient sur son site.
Mais pour les historiens.
Sa version est peu crédible.
Il est impossible d'imaginer,
Que les représentants d'I.G.Farben sur place,
Et même les plus hauts dirigeants de l'entreprise,
Aient ignorer ce qui se passait sur ce camp situé à proximité du leur.
Même si le processus d'**** était relativement discret,
Il n'est pas crédible que les dirigeants sur place,
De I.G.Farben ai pu l'ignorer.
Peut être ont ils fermé les yeux,
Ont-ils pas voulu savoir véritablement les détails,
Mais ils en avaient forcément entendu parler.
L'odeur, ils savent,
Ils peuvent sentir les corps brûlés.
Ils vivent dans un environnement qu'ils savent être un centre de ****.
La charge de crimes contre l'humanité n'est pas retenu.
Otto Ambris est condamné pour asservissement,
À 8 ans de prison.
Libéré en 1952,
Il poursuivra sa carrière de chimiste aux Etats-Unis,
Avant de revenir en Allemagne,
Où il mourra à l'âge de 89 ans.
L'entreprise, elle,
A été démantelée en plusieurs sociétés qui sont toujours en activité,
Comme Agfa, BASF,
Ou encore le géant pharmaceutique Bayer.
Aujourd'hui, IG Farben n'existe plus.
Me demander ce que IG Farben a laissé dans ma mémoire,
Elle n'a pas seulement laissé un passé.
Elle a laissé un présent,
Et elle a laissé un présent de vigilance,
De combat,
De militance,
Pour que jamais ces forces là,
Ne retrouvent la puissance,
Qu'ils croyaient avoir acquise pour un millénaire.
Je suis un rescapé,
De ce temps là.
Je suis un vainqueur et pas un vaincu.
Un vainqueur.